[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday
25 years ago today one of the deadliest
aircraft disasters in american history
shook the world 230 people were on board
twa
flight 800 when the 747 jet bound from
new york to paris
exploded off the coast of long island
now the reconstructed wreckage is being
decommissioned and destroyed after being
carefully mapped and photographed over a
long period
errol barnett looks back at how this
disaster changed
aviation and so many lives forever
he was a harvard hockey player
and i was a new college graduate heidi
snow senator and her fiance michelle
bristoff had
one last phone call before his trip to
paris aboard twa
flight 800. we exchanged her final i
love views and he
told me he'd call me when he got to
paris we are about 6000 feet hovering
above the wreckage
but when her mother phoned telling her
to turn on the television
everything changed i saw the
tw 800 debris burning on the dark
atlantic ocean
and everything we had planned together
started to shatter
minutes after takeoff from jfk at almost
14
000 feet 230 passengers and crew from 10
countries
experienced a mid-air explosion the fuel
was
burning the water and you couldn't stand
the smell
or the fumes they were just burning your
eyes
one of the first reporters on the scene
cbs news senior investigative producer
pat
milton who at the time was with the
associated press
i remember there was one young man and
here he was
hauling bodies into the boat but
treating them with such
dignity and grace it was just an
incredible incredible experience to see
there were no survivors public outcry
was immediate
and suspecting a crime the fbi launched
an exhaustive investigation
they thought that this was a terrorist
act
it captured the world trawlers vacuuming
the ocean floor
sifting through sediment for clues what
followed was one of the longest fbi
investigations of its time
and one of the longest ntsb probes to
this day
this is where the the main explosion
initiated
this is the area of interest frank
hildrop who was among the first
ntsb investigators on site says
reconstructing the doomed aircraft
a rare move for the safety board was
essential we wanted to be able to
view and display the
the center wing tank to demonstrate
where the event occurred
and how the spark may have been
introduced to it it took 16 months for
the fbi to rule out terrorism and more
than four years and 40 million dollars
for the ntsb to conclude
the explosion was most likely caused by
a short circuit
outside of the center wing tank this
changed the way planes were built
specifically how fuel tanks were
constructed
a tragedy has resulted
in a number of significant improvements
both in aviation as well as in
victim assistance family assistants the
wreckage has been off limits to cameras
sitting in this virginia ntsb
facility since 2003 a sacred teaching
tool for crash investigators
but with the lease here expiring this
wreckage is being destroyed
and won't go to a museum due to family
wishes
it's lessons moving online can a virtual
environment
ever really replace being here in real
life i think that's the question we're
all asking ourselves
as we've gone through the pandemic our
ability to reach others
i think increases significantly by doing
it this way
and and i won't i won't disagree i i do
think we
may lose a little something in that
process
senator who is now married with children
spent the last 25 years running her
bereavement non-profit
called access now one of her daughters
is helping
other kids i have an older daughter who
actually has come forward and started
make her own initiative to help children
by putting together a project called
comfort kits for kids
where she actually puts together grief
kits and toys and
comforting objects to send to kids who
are in grief
what is the legacy of twa flight 800
it's the preciousness of life the fact
that you did have
ordinary people doing extraordinary
things
to not only try to recover victims but
try to
solve what happened to this plane crash
the investigators were driven
to find out and they were driven because
of their relationships with the families
the cbs this morning saturday errol
barnett washington
one of these mysteries that has just
endured
and it's one of those uh situations
where so many of the people who died on
that flight were from
the same community out in long island it
was
it's just hit them so hard i remember
covering one of the anniversaries and
it's just
it's it's just heartbreaking i mean and
when we see those those are those
mileposts that you say i remember where
i was i remember when that happened and
the fear then
was the thought that it was a bomb or
something like that and then there were
no answers for so long
and the good things to come out of this
horror what the kids have done and also
the way that planes have changed
learn from the tragedy as they talk to
them always